Okay, Rona Segev, thank you so much
for being on my show 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Good. Thank you for inviting me.
Hi.
I am so honored to have you here.
We've been trying to do this for a while.
And I'm so happy that you feel better
and that we're finally getting to do this
because you're one of the
leading investors in Israel.
A founding partner at TLV Partners,
one of the leading
investor funds in Israel.
But you're also
a general partner of Pitango,
with countless of successful investments
over the past years,
both in the Israeli tech industry
and outside of it.
Rona, who are you?
So, give me a little bit of background
as to who you are and how do you get
to become a leading investor?
Wow, who am I.
It's just the first question.
Well, I can tell you about
how I started my career,
which is kind of weird.
I started by learning
psychology and philosophy
in the Hebrew University,
nothing to do with high tech.
When I was 24, I had this crazy idea
to do something in computers.
It was '95.
We didn't have VCs in Israel back then
and I didn't know the world, the startup.
So, everything was really really new.
But I found someone who was crazy enough
to give me two 200K and we started.
And eventually what we did was
we were a company that was developing
shoot 'em up games
like really hardcore gaming company.
We developed three games,
one of them even became a hit, big hit.
Okay.
There is even a retro about it.
You can get that from the internet
if you want to embarrass me,
it's called Virus.
And then I sold the company
when I was 27.
Wow.
Then pregnant
with my first set of twins.
So, I have two sets of twins.
Wow, that's amazing.
Two sets of twins. Wow.
Yeah.
And the main reason
I joined the VC back then
was because I thought to myself,
"Well, you're now a young mom,
for at least two or three years
it's probably not very wise
to be an entrepreneur again."
"Let's do something easier."
And this is why I joined
the VC community.
I joined Evergreen back then.
Incredible.
So, take me back because it sounds like
there's a little bit of discrepancy
between where you are at 24
and what you've studied
to going into the gaming industry.
What was the trigger there?
Why gaming?
We started with something which was,
the initial concept was taking Lego
and putting it on computers.
But at that time, there was something
which was called edutainment,
and we found ourselves inside the segment,
which was a horrible segment.
Full of multimedia CDs.
And I just didn't like it.
I told to myself,
"We don't want to be there."
And then we said,
"Okay, let's take this robot
that we're building
with those Lego
and let's go and fight."
And we just basically
kind of copied DOOM
and started to do games
which are very similar to DOOM,
and things followed each other.
Wonderful.
Yeah. And very quickly we became
a pure gaming company.
And that is until you're 27
where you sell the company,
you become  a VC
and you start to invest
in other companies.
Talk to me a little bit
about this transition
going from entrepreneur to an investor
and what are some of the thought processes
that take you throughout this journey?
So, it was
a very humbling experience, actually,
because I was an entrepreneur
in the gaming industry.
And when I joined Evergreen
and we were dividing fields among us
and no one wanted
enterprise software and security.
It's funny, but back then
we're talking about '99, 2000,
it wasn't considered to be
a very good area to invest in.
So, and I was the most junior,
the new junior female partner.
So, they gave me,
they handed me this segment.
And then I started to invest
in enterprise software
I didn't know anything.
So, and really, sometimes I apologize
for entrepreneurs I met back then
because I just sit right there
and they were talking about
all kind of like weird stuff,
which now are so natural to me.
But back then, I just really
I didn't understand a word.
I remember the first three months
I was going back home to my husband
every night and crying saying,
"I will never understand
what they're talking about."
Wow.
But I was just asking a lot.
But I just started asking,
I was asking questions constantly.
And this is one thing
that I've learned since,
never to be ashamed
that you don't know something.
You can learn. Okay?
Just tell the person,
"You know, I'm not familiar."
"Can you please tell me more about it?"
And so, the first year and after years,
I was basically listening and learning.
And became close friends
with different entrepreneurs
and different people in the industry.
And I was just going
and asking for explanations
and then I started to invest.
And I was lucky I must say.
Because I think, when I started to invest
in enterprise software and security,
this was exactly the time,
it was like 2002, that those areas
became hot areas in Israel.
And most of the exit be coming at
enterprise software and security,
and here I was, in the perfect time,
in the perfect industry
just starting my career.
And very quickly
I started to have my [--]
and the rest is history.
But I think it's interesting
because they say a lot that
to be a successful entrepreneur,
timing is one of the most critical aspect.
It's not just about your team
and about your execution,
it's about whether the market is ripe
for your execution to go into that market.
And it sounds like
that's a very similar experience
to what you had as an investor.
You're coming in, its 2002,
the cybersecurity space
and enterprise space is booming in Israel.
And you get to be there
just as you've built the confidence
to just start making these investments.
And so, one of the things
that we chatted previously
just a little bit about,
and I'd love to elaborate here,
is this whole notion of
what it takes to succeed
in the field that you're in.
While I'm sure that a lot of times
it may be cutthroat
and it's very competitive,
I read in a few places
your take on the type of personality
that you can be
as you go about your journey.
So, talk to me a little bit about that.
I think, one of the things that
I didn't like about my career
and I didn't like about the industry,
and I'm not talking
specifically about Israel,
though that we see it a lot in Israel,
I also I'm working a lot
with VCs in the US
and I see it also in the US,
and it's a culture
which is very very aggressive
and I call it very focused
on short term optimization.
And the reason I'm calling it
short term optimization is because
sometimes I feel that
whenever two people are in the room
arguing about something,
someone has to win
no matter what are the consequences.
And it doesn't matter even if it's like
how much you get for your lunch every day,
or covering your travel costs
or stuff like that, which are
totally insignificant for the company
and can really damage the company
if the employees feel
that they're not getting enough.
But still, just because of the dynamics
of power in the room,
many times it's very hurtful
at the end of the day to the company.
I felt it also in the relationship
between VCs and entrepreneurs.
If you think about it,
and really if you take all the noise
and just focus on the essence of our job,
the only way that we can be successful
is if our companies and our entrepreneurs
will be successful.
And really it's everything about
VC investment.
So, if you start playing around
with the entrepreneurs firing them,
the chances of your companies
to be successful are reduced dramatically.
So, basically you are investing in people
and really the aim of this investment,
and what will make me successful is that
if my entrepreneurs will be successful.
And everything is built around that.
And so, I didn't understand
why people are fighting
with their entrepreneurs so much,
why they're trying
to squeeze them out of things,
why are they not creating these
alliance of interest and working together.
This was something that really bothered me
for many many years.
And this was one of the drivers
of starting TLV partners,
to prove to myself, first of all,
that we can be very successful
and work differently.
Sometimes I think that
people are seeing too many American movies
and we are too much influenced about TV
that the successful figures
are always vicious and aggressive
and totally concentrated on their needs.
And we grow up thinking
that this is the only way
to be successful.
And I actually see it
because I grew up in Jerusalem,
I just truly believe that it's not true.
That actually working with people
in collaboration
and creating a win-win environment
will actually create a situation
where people want to work with you
again and again.
They recommend their friends,
and it's just fun working like that.
Just everyone enjoys working together
instead of suffering
and being in conflict, constant conflict.
100%.
So, the forming of TLV Partners,
today every entrepreneur in Israel
and many abroad know of  TLV partners,
but talk to me the early days.
So, going back to just starting out,
previously, you were at Pitango,
another wonderful
investment firm in Israel.
So, I understand the trigger
to form TLV partners.
It's your own,
there is a different mentality,
you're defining the culture.
So, a lot of entrepreneurs that I talk to
they're talking about how culture
was one of the things that they set out
to concentrate on from day one.
You're saying also,
it's the same thing in VC.
I want my partners and myself
to have a certain culture
with our founders.
What are some of the greatest challenges
and maybe joyous events
of starting TLV partners
in throughout this journey?
So the first thing was just going out
and pitching this message,
as I just told you,
to employees, to our investors.
And I was really scared.
I thought that they're looking
to seek people with knives like
walking around like with blood dripping.
And I was hoping that
they would look at me and say,
she's weak or she's too nice,
or it won't work.
But we were very true to our message
because really, we actually really believe
that this is something
that we wanted to do.
It was very important to us
that our employees would understand
what is the culture
that we're trying to build.
It turned out that just like
two or three years before,
as many of the employees
started to realize that VCs that are
actually following this type of culture
are more successful or are as successful
as very tough and cruel VCs
because the entrepreneurs like them;
because they recommend others
to come and get their money;
because overall, the experience
working with them is more pleasant.
So, entrepreneurs are more focused
on building the company
and not fighting with the VCs.
Right.
Actually, it was received very well
this message, which was a big surprise,
a very pleasant surprise
to what we've done
and we raised our first fund very quickly.
It took us a few months
to raise $110,000,000.
In Israel, this is amazing.
At that time, this was 2015,
VCs were raising funds for three years.
It took them three years
to raise the funds.
And we raised like,
from really really tough year
here in the US.
I remember when we did the closing,
I was so happy.
I just couldn't believe that we made it.
It's like an entrepreneur
raising a fund.
It's totally.
We have foreign investors,
were going out there asking for money,
someone is saying "no" many times
just because they don't like us.
It's pretty similar actually. Yeah.
How is your relationship
with the founders that you invest in?
And I know quite a few of them.
And so, I know that
it's a wonderful relationship.
But I'd like to know a little bit
about your side of it.
So, as a VC, you get to meet
with your entrepreneurs once in a while.
You get to help them on their journey.
You're in the trenches with them,
obviously, in a lot of the cases.
What are some of the key points in time
that you're valuable for the entrepreneurs
that work with you?
So, first of all, it's really important
to say that it's very different
with each entrepreneur
because they're different people.
So, it's just like with everyone,
like you have one personality
and another personality
and there is a natural connection.
Sometimes it goes one way,
sometimes it's very intimate,
sometimes just very friendly,
it really depends.
And some of them are calling me
like 20 times a day,
some of them are calling me once a month.
And we have always, I book an hour
for each entrepreneur every week.
And they know they can cancel it
whenever they want.
I don't care, it's for them.
It's not for me, okay?
I get a free hour. It's fine.
Right.
So, this is something
which is really important
and those relationships
are also changing with time.
So, as we get to know each other better
we are becoming more intimate
and kind of like and different.
And this is something
which for me is important
because those are real relationship.
It's not something that
you just turn on and off.
It's like real friendships
and they're there forever.
One of the things that they know
is that I really do care,
and not just about the company,
but also about them personally.
I do believe that people and companies
are interconnected.
And I think that happy entrepreneurs
are better entrepreneurs.
And I really like entrepreneurs.
I invest and I insist on investing
in people that I like,
I really personally like.
So, we're going to have fun
working together.
That's amazing. Wow.
But how do you go about
the due diligence process then?
How do you find that connection?
Because even if you do get to meet them
a few times, I imagine that the scenario
through the limited experience
that I now have
with a venture fund that I work with,
you get to build some repertoire
and relationship with the founders,
but it's still in the context of
three or four meetings.
It's not like going camping with them
and seeing them in necessarily
in their true 100% colors, right?
So, it sounds like
there's a little bit of a challenge there
to really find that personal fit,
or maybe I'm wrong.
No, no, no. It is.
Listen, I invest many in seed companies
and I really like new markets, okay?
So, markets that do not exist yet.
The real problem in investing
if I think about it, so first of all,
and I love first time entrepreneurs,
so I think 70% of my investments are first timers.
So, I invest in people
that have no track record.
So, I can't check their track record
in markets that do not exist.
So, there is not a lot of point
talking to customers,
a lot of time they don't know
what I'm talking about even.
So, most of the time goes to
working with the entrepreneur.
So, it's weird.
So, really honestly,
my due diligence is very intuitive
and it's a lot about
how I feel about the people.
And if I think that
they are really bright, very open,
very transparent,
and we can work together
and I call it going together
to an adventure, because I know that
everything is going to change.
The reason for that change
is the group that is working together.
This is why I also like to invest a lot
in seed stage because
it's a very intimate relationship.
A lot of things are changing constantly.
I don't want them to feel uncomfortable
with them changing things.
On the contrary, I want them to move
and I want them to brainstorm with me,
they'll tell me that I'm wrong
or I'm stupid
and feel comfortable saying that
and insist on doing their own way
because they're the ones
who are going to be blamed eventually
if it's not going the right way.
So, they have to take the decisions.
There is a circle of
responsibility and authority
that has to be close together.
And so, it's really important
that they'll take the decision.
So, they need to be
very comfortable with me.
And not think that
I tell them what to do.
So, it's a combination.
I learn a lot about people
when I'm doing the negotiation
on the term sheet with them.
The way I'm doing negotiations
is actually very funny.
I come with the coffee table
and we play with it together
and I find it very fair deal
to everyone and with most entrepreneurs.
Wait, you come with the what?
What did you say?
We have an interactive coffee table.
So, we just come
and we just play with the numbers.
Okay, got you.
It's kind of like [--]
between two to three minutes, okay.
It really depends how long
because it's really easy.
Really?
Yeah.
Because I know that
I don't want to allude them too much
and they need
a certain amount of money
and we need some [--].
So, it's actually, everything about
a VC-entrepreneurs relationship
is actually really really simple.
And then you see
some entrepreneurs are just so happy
to see this approach.
And like in five minutes,
we close the deal and we move on.
And some entrepreneurs try to optimize.
And those entrepreneurs are usually shy away
because my kind of attitude,
you can't take advantage of me.
So, I take care, I work with people
that enjoy this kind of attitude.
It's like giving and they give back
and we just enjoy working together.
So, from time to time I make mistakes
but it's very rare, actually.
our workers are really greatful people
and they enjoy working.
Rona, that's just inspiring.
I can imagine my hand on the situation.
One set of the regular VC experience
that I think
every young entrepreneur imagine is
sitting coming with suits,
negotiating over a table,
sending emails in,
and over weeks trying to decide
on those two percentage points
here and there.
Whereas you come and meet
at a coffee shop,
do an interactive coffee table
and give a hug and continue the hug
before caorona times, of course,
and continue with the day.
Rona, I can't believe
20 minutes are almost over,
but I have two important questions
before we leave.
The first one is to me.
Something that a young entrepreneur
like myself or like a lot of my friends,
either from 8200 or Stanford,
what can we take with us
from this personal insight that you had
of being sort of a mensch
and being a good person
going throughout our career,
what is something that we can keep in mind
to try to do that with that aim?
So, first of all, believe.
Really believe in yourself
and believe that it's okay to be firm
and to be mensch and to be good.
And it's not like you're weak.
Sometimes people around us
will consider it weakness, it's not.
It's actually being strong.
And second, pick the right people
around you, okay?
You cannot be fair if you have people
that are over optimizing,
that are manipulating around you.
Pick the right people around you,
people that actually enjoy
this kind of culture
and everyone will have so much fun
working together.
Amazing. Amazing.
Rona, last one,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
There is this guy that I really like
in the Valley that looked at me
like a year ago and told me,
"You're such a strange bird."
So, this is my three words.
I love it. I love it.
Rona, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
This was inspiring.
I just love getting to know you better.
And I look forward to coming one day
with my own idea
and potentially collaborating together.
This is just wonderful
what you're doing there.
Thank you.
Bye. Bye.